close that robe
sir both sexes love a cutie but men gain
more from beauty true men can earn a lot
just by being smoking hot turns out men
benefit the most in life from being
good-looking but that's just one of the
reasons I have two TV shows Julie a I
knew it also there are those movies I
start in to pay for college but we won't
get into that
here it's according to a new study from
the Polish Academy of Science Sciences I
do love their
parois ah yes the Polish Academy of
Sciences always answering the tough
questions in life although their
researchers still don't know how many of
them it takes to screw in a light bulb
remember those jokes I don't over the
course of 20 years researchers found
people who were more attractive as
teenagers were more likely to be
successful in life everything from earn
earnings jobs and education the hot
people just did better although ugly
guys can still make it if they
try
[Applause]
just let it sit even taken into account
things like so socioeconomic status and
health being easier in the eyes made a
significant impact on people's lives but
it was the men in particular who
benefited the most but hey good-looking
men are just better at everything I
guess including being
women uh Joe I'm going to read another
question uh written by one of our WR you
got to fire these guys yeah as a homely
ugly
male when did you realize you just had
to work harder to achieve just a sh uh a
shred of success and yet you still
haven't been able to do that you must
really suck it's not even really a
question not even really a
question uh Greg this may surprise you
uh when I was a teenager I was a bit of
an ugly duckling oh really we could put
up a little evidence there that
that is amazing is that you that's
that's me uh apparently I was on some
sort of welding team with those oh my
God you know what you must okay so this
is a class picture this is definitely a
class picture and you were so excited to
wear your Rush t-shirt was yes I'm so
excited dad did you get that Rush
t-shirt from a concert no I bought it in
like a crappy record store yeah it
wasn't even was a bootleg was not even a
licensed product yeah and I heard about
it when I got home too W so what you're
like a caterpillar that blossomed into
another caterpillar I did and look at me
now I'm a I'm a beautiful Swan you're a
beautiful please now make that go away I
don't like sitting next to it like this
why are you wearing women's sunglasses
it was popular then I maintain it was
popular to literally look through
rose-colored glasses rosec colored not
your mom's
glasses now here's the people com
complain about oh the world favors tall
handsome wealthy men and I don't know
why they complain to me about that cuz
that's not the system I would come up
with you know where's the system that
favors short humorous
soft-handed you know talented wonderful
people like
me no you're right there are no protest
organizations for the homely right
exactly you know what I mean there's no
parades there's no like you know
unattractive uh rights alliances and
they're the ones that are discriminated
the most you got AC let's face it even a
racist would sleep with h
Berry wasn't that a movie wasn't that
monsters ball I think it was yes yeah
either that or medical condition but my
point being that like looks trumps
everything including Prejudice you know
cat uh this came from the Polish Academy
of Science H you you are a Polish could
you explain these findings okay do you
know anybody
there yeah we all know each
other uh look I uh I hate to belittle my
own people yeah but I just think I get
why they did it this way so they wanted
to rate them when they were 15 because
if you are an adult sometimes you can
make money and make yourself better
looking uh but I just don't know what
researchers would do this if I went to
go participate in a study and I sit down
there like okay this 15-year-old minor
Hot or
Not I'd be I'd be like I'm sorry but I
have to go that's you know I didn't even
I didn't even occur to me that this
possibly is illegal I just or you know
this is you know you're you're you a cop
Paul this is a great front for perverts
I'm doing a study I would like you're 15
I'd like to talk to you about way too
interested in this
aspect just remember the internet is
forever pal yeah you know I remember
David Lee Roth was once asked by a rock
critic why do rock critics prefer Elvis
Costello to Van Halen and he said
because most Rock critics look like like
Elvis Castello yeah you that's an
analogy you understand yes I do that's
all I have to say when you talk I always
feel like you you're supposed to say do
you want me to get you a sandwich we're
going to come in here with the LI
detector test that's right look we have
that put you we have somebody that puts
you right there at the seat of the crime
what this study doesn't explain is uh
Jerry Nadler yeah right you're supposed
to be good-looking you're going to get a
head in life how did that happen no yeah
that's true he actually ate a lot of
good-looking
people it's true Julie you're a human
woman uh we we have yet to do tests but
results haven't come back yes yes thank
you do you um do you buy this and do
here's my theory it's not that
attractive people are more successful
it's that unattractive people are
discriminated against and I and and I
think that is something we just don't
want to admit right well I think it's
great that you made it
thank I'm proud of you I think it's good
you know I couldn't be tall because God
knows what would have happened I mean
look at me now CU then you'd be like a
double threat I would be a double threat
no I agree it is true that more
attractive people tend to have it harder
I did not bring any childhood pictures I
would not have been in that category oh
my God like just fat and I was in band
that's all I would I would never have
thought that I would have actually made
it here working along such attractive
successful men like yourself yes I also
think that it's more acceptable to say a
guy's hot whereas now a woman you can't
say that in the office God forbid I talk
about men's asses all the time you know
it's funny I haven't been in HR once
yeah I don't you know it's true it's
like on and when we used to do the
introductions for red eye I would say
she's so hot and I'd say something I
don't do that anymore I know but I don't
care I think people are too sensitive
like who cares if you're hot own it so
now you just say horrifically mean thing
yes all right I had other points to make
but we must move on coming up it was
just about to clap for me and you cut
them off
Jesus that clapping was for
me don't steal my
clapter coming up a rocker dropped the
guitar and they started to spar hey Sean
hanity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else